ben hall fox news
thank you
uh thank you very much both uh list
today
um foreign minister
there is a suggestion that what we've
seen so far is a minor invasion that
there's more to come and so it only
warrants
sort of lesser u.s sanctions i wonder if
that is your read as well and also you
and president zielenski called for tough
sanctions to be placed on russia before
the invasion you said this would happen
if not it has happened are you happy
with that in mind with the way the u.s
has handled this what more would you
like to see from the u.s and from the
international community to try and deter
more aggression
and uh secretary blanken thank you
given that russia has invaded ukraine
regardless of all the threats of harsh
sanctions the attempts at diplomacy what
makes you think that continuing down the
same path is going to deter them any
further do you think it's time to change
tact do you think diplomacy has failed
and secondly have you underestimated
putin
first there is no such thing as minor in
middle or
major invasion invasion is an invasion
second as i said
earlier
we do appreciate
today's the sanctions which were
announced today they target russia
they're very specific they are painful
i can say frankly that yesterday when we
learned about the first executive order
to impose sanctions on act related to
economic activities in the donetsk uh
with donetsk and lugansk
we were puzzled
because we saw
how the site
that
thought recognition from russia is being
punished
but we didn't see how russia who granted
its recognition is punished but we saw
it today and this strategy of
imposing sanctions by waves if i may put
it this way
is something that
that can work
if
it continues in a very sustained in a
sustainable way president putin should
not have a single minute
when
he starts to think
that this is the threshold this is the
the sea the pressure reached its ceiling
and he will not be punished anymore
this pressure should continue to be
stepped up
and
if that involves
regular issuance of
executive orders on new sanctions we
will be more than happy to see to see
that
i will repeat again
we
can despite the horrific address by
president putin
where he basically challenged the very
or rejected he didn't challenge he
rejected the very existence of the
ukrainian state
we can still stop him
if we act in a very resolved way and
keep
mounting pressure on him
the question is that he has a certain
table on his mind which i'm not aware of
but i'm sure he has it
and we should also understand that
every next decision
should be taken in a swift action and we
saw two executive orders issued by the
president by president biden within what
less than 24 hours
this
may be the dynamics that will have to be
upheld
if
russia continues to escalate and it was
encouraging to hear from secretary
a very simple sentence if russia
escalates the united states and partners
will escalate sanctions this is exactly
the rule that has to be followed
and yes we did believe
that
it would be helpful
for
some of sanctions not all of sanctions
but some of sanctions to be imposed
before
the invasion begins as a preemptive
measure
for what russia had done before
but this question becomes obsolete now
and we have to focus on a different
strategy the one that i just described
then it's hard for me to improve much on
my friend dimitro's answer i'll just add
a couple of things
first
all along we said that we were
pursuing
uh two tracks
the track of diplomacy and dialogue
to try to persuade
russia not to engage in renewed
aggression
against ukraine and at the same time a
track where we were building up
deterrence
building up defense and building
a response that would have massive
consequences for russia
russia has clearly chosen to reject
diplomacy and dialogue and instead to
pursue aggression
as a consequence
we have started to pursue
the severe consequences that we've made
clear would follow from any renewed
russian aggression
today
faced with the beginning of russia's
invasion of ukraine
we started high and will stay high um
the sanctions that we've already
announced
go well beyond what we did in in 2014
full blocking sanctions against two of
russia's largest financial institutions
veb and the the military bank
these institutions hold more than 80
billion dollars in assets they provide
key services that are critical
to financing the kremlin and russian
military
we have comprehensive sanctions against
russian sovereign debt what that means
is that we're cutting off the russian
government from western financing
sanctions on elites and family members
and
as promised as we've said all
along germany taking action
on nordstrom 2.
and to repeat what dimitro just
emphasized
we've also made clear we're making clear
today
that if russia continues to escalate
so will we um and of course it's not
only uh the sanctions and other measures
uh of that uh that nature that are being
taken
it is as we've made clear the
reinforcement of nato on its eastern
flank
and continuing to provide and indeed
increase the support that we're
providing to ukraine against
every dimension
security
diplomatic political economic
humanitarian all of that
is in the mix
ultimately
president putin
makes whatever decisions he makes
we do we can do everything in our uh
power to try to
shape those decisions but
as i've said all along whatever his
decisions
we're prepared either way and we've
demonstrated that again today in full
coordination with allies and partners
oh i think to the contrary
we've not underestimated him we've
actually laid out for the world
uh his entire playbook a playbook that
he is now following
and is making uh very clear that
for example what the president's laid
out what i laid out at the united
nations a week ago
is exactly what's happening so we've had
a very clear-eyed view
of president putin all along
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else